I want to briefly talk about Ivanka
Trump many of you emailed me about this
story Ivanka Trump is refusing to be
involved with Donald Trump's 2024 run
now she is putting a very positive spin
on it there's an article in the cut
which summarizes this called Ivanka
would prefer not to the article is by
Claire lampin it was published yesterday
and it includes a transcript of ivanka's
Instagram post where she said
um I love my father very much
this time around I'm choosing to
prioritize my young children and the
private life we are creating together as
a family I do not plan to be involved in
politics while I will always love and
support my father going forward I will
do so outside the political Arena I am
grateful to have had the honor of
serving the American people and I will
always be proud of many of our
administration's accomplishments
listen
um this has been a building Fiasco for
Jared and Ivanka and I have to say you
know this isn't about I think ivanka's
great but it has always struck me that
from the adult children and I include
Jared Kushner and this as the son-in-law
that Ivanka most accurately had the
pulse
uh
understood the pulse of what the
perception of trump and his kids was and
we had numerous reports when Trump's
term was waning and it was you know he
had lost already he was claiming he was
going to figure out a way to stay but it
was obvious he was leaving there were
these reports about how Jared and Ivanka
were struggling with the fact that their
old Social Circles were refusing they
were they were not welcoming them back
in and there were a bunch of different
stories that you can find about this and
then in the lead-up to Donald Trump's
announcement on Tuesday night there was
also reporting about Trump has been
begging Jared and Ivanka to be there and
it's not clear whether they are going to
be there and at the end of the day
Ivanka wasn't there and Jared Kushner
was I actually respect this more than
anything I've ever seen Ivanka do of
course she was in way over her head even
being involved with this Administration
she had no business there remember when
she sat in for then Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson at like the G something
Summit it's all completely and utterly
insane but the most responsible and
respectful uh uh thing that Ivanka has
done here is to recognize this was a
humiliation and hey you know what she
values her personal life she values her
social life she realizes that it was
humiliating what happened I am sure that
she still thinks that good things were
done by her dad I don't I don't think
she thinks it was a disaster but she
increasingly recognizes the cartoonish
nature of what went on around the
January 6 riots there are reports that
Ivanka was horrified by what was going
on and wasn't thrilled with Donald
Trump's response so
I understand why she's not just coming
out and saying this was a complete
humiliation to my my personal family
right her and her kids
there is probably all sorts of crazy
stuff going on in terms of her versus
Jared because for now it seems that
Jared is standing behind Trump although
it increasingly seems like he's not go
he would not be a part of an upcoming
Trump Administration this actually is
the most logical thing I've ever heard
of Ivanka doing she should have no
involvement it's been a humiliation it's
been bad for her it's obviously terrible
for her kids
and this is clearly the right decision
so good for Ivanka I think it makes
sense and the question now remains
uh what's Jared going to do on a
personal level I don't care but it is
interesting to see the difference
between Eric and Don Jr who are clearly
Full Speed Ahead on this and Ivanka who
seems a little bit more reflective and
thoughtful about the disaster that this
has been for their family
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below